c'est étonnant non
[Musique]
afin de ne pas être ridicule en société
il faut absolument savoir reconnaître
une gardienne d'immeuble donne oléoducs
certes à première vue rien ne les
distingue l'un de l'autre mais avec un
peu d'entraînement nous devons y arriver
alors et alors seulement nous ne serons
plus celui dont on rit en disant ah il a
donné des étrennes à son oléoduc ou
encore à il a rempli sa conscience de
pétrole mais comment faire dire unis et
bien c'est très simple
regardez bien paulette je m'appelle
pauline bouchard avec un dé et ben oui
vous avez compris le pipeline s'appelle
paulette et la pipelette s'appelle
pauline
etonnant non
[Musique]
c'est non non